Creo que deberíamos estar más dispuestos, tal vez,
a mirar el hermoso espectáculo de la luz del Sol estallando
detrás de las nubes y pensar, "Espera un minuto,
¡son dos gatos bailando salsa!"
(Risas) (Aplausos)
O ver esta nube grande, blanca y esponjosa
sobre el centro comercial que parece
el abominable hombre de las nieves que va a robar un banco.
(Risas)
Son como la versión de la naturaleza de esas manchas de tinta,
que los psicólogos les mostraban a sus pacientes
en los años 60,
y creo que si tienen en cuenta las formas que ven en las nubes,
ahorrarán dinero en las facturas del psicoanálisis.
Supongamos que están enamorados.
Miran hacia arriba y ¿qué ven?
¿Cierto? O tal vez lo contrario.
Los acaba de dejar su pareja,
y dondequiera que miran, ven parejas besándose.
(Risas)
Tal vez están pasando por un momento de angustia existencial.
Ya saben, están pensando en su propia muerte.
Y allí, en el horizonte, está la Parca.
(Risas)
O tal vez vean una bañista en topless.
¿Qué significa esto?
¿Qué significa esto? No tengo ni idea.
Pero lo que sí sé es esto:
La mala fama que tienen las nubes es totalmente injusta.
Creo que deberíamos defenderlas,
razón por la que, hace unos años
fundé la Cloud Appreciation Society.
Ya cuenta con decenas de miles de miembros
en casi 100 países del mundo.
Y todas estas fotografías que estoy mostrando
han sido enviadas por ellos.
Y esta sociedad existe para recordarle a la gente esto:
Las nubes no son algo de lo que quejarse.
Al contrario. Son, de hecho,
el aspecto más variado, evocador y poético de la naturaleza.
Creo que vivir con la cabeza en las nubes
de vez en cuando, ayuda a mantener los pies en el suelo.
Y quiero mostrarles el por qué, con la ayuda de
algunos de mis tipos favoritos de nubes.
Vamos a empezar con este. Es un cirro, nombre que viene
de la palabra latina para designar un mechón de pelo.
Se compone en su totalidad de cristales de hielo
cayendo en cascada desde la parte superior de la troposfera.
Conforme estos cristales de hielo caen,
pasan a través de diferentes capas con diferentes vientos
que los aceleran y frenan,
dándole a la nube esta apariencia de cepillado,
estas formas de pinceladas conocidas como mechones caídos.
Y estos vientos allá arriba pueden ser muy feroces.
Pueden ser de entre 300 y 500 km por hora.
Estas nubes van muy rápido,
pero desde aquí abajo
parecen moverse con gracia, lentamente,
como casi todas las nubes.
Así que para sintonizarse con las nubes hay que ir despacio,
calmarse.
Es como un poco de meditación diaria.
Estas son nubes comunes.
¿Qué pasa con las más raras, como las lenticulares,
las nubes lenticulares con forma de ovni?
Estas nubes se forman en regiones montañosas.
Cuando hay viento, este se eleva para sobrepasar la montaña,
y puede ondularse en la curva del pico,
con estas nubes flotando en la cima
de estas ondas de aire estacionarias e invisibles,
estas formas como de platillo volador,
y algunas de las primeras fotos en blanco y negro de ovnis,
son de hecho nubes lenticulares. Es cierto.
Un poco más raras son los nubes agujero.
Las vemos cuando una capa de gotas de agua
muy, muy frías empiezan a congelarse en una región,
y esta congelación pone en marcha una reacción en cadena que se extiende hacia el exterior
con los cristales de hielo cayendo en cascada,
dando la apariencia de tentáculos de medusa.
Más rara aún es la nube Kelvin-Helmholtz.
No es un nombre muy elegante. Necesita que se lo cambien.
Esta nube parece una sucesión de olas rompiéndose,
y esto es causado por vientos de corte: los vientos
por encima y por debajo de la capa de nubes
difieren significativamente, y en el centro, en medio,
se consigue esta ondulación del aire,
y si la diferencia de velocidades es la adecuada,
la parte superior de los rizos se ondula
en estos hermosos vórtices ondulatorios.
Son nubes más inusuales que el cirro,
pero no son tan inusuales.
Si alzan su mirada y prestan atención al cielo,
las verán tarde o temprano,
tal vez no vean nubes tan impresionantes como estas, pero las verán.
Y las verán en la zona donde viven.
Las nubes son el espectáculo
más igualitario de la naturaleza, porque todos tenemos
una fantástica vista del cielo.
Y estas nubes, las más inusuales,
nos recuerdan que lo exótico puede encontrarse en lo cotidiano.
No hay nada más revitalizante, más estimulante
para una mente activa y curiosa, que ser sorprendida,
ser maravillada. Por eso estamos todos aquí, en TED, ¿cierto?
Pero no tienen que precipitarse
lejos de lo familiar, al otro lado del mundo,
para ser sorprendidos.
Solo tienen que salir,
prestar atención a lo que es tan común, tan cotidiano,
tan mundano, que el resto del mundo lo pasa por alto.
Una nube que la gente rara vez echa de menos es esta:
la nube de tormenta cumulonimbo.
Es la que produce truenos, rayos y granizo.
Estas nubes se extienden sobre esta enorme
forma de yunque, desplegándose 16 km hacia arriba en la atmósfera.
Son una expresión de la majestuosa arquitectura
de nuestra atmósfera.
Pero desde abajo, son la encarnación
de la fuerza poderosa y elemental
que impulsa nuestra atmósfera.
Estar ahí es estar conectado con la lluvia
y el granizo, sentirse conectado a nuestra atmósfera.
Hay que recordar que somos criaturas
que habitan en este océano de aire.
No vivimos bajo el cielo. Vivimos dentro de él.
Y esa conexión visceral con nuestra atmósfera
me parece un antídoto.
Un antídoto a la creciente tendencia que tenemos
de sentir que realmente podemos experimentar la vida
viéndola en una pantalla de computadora,
cuando estamos en una zona wi-fi.
Pero las nubes que mejor expresan
por qué hoy es más importante que nunca observarlas
son estas, los cúmulos.
¿Verdad? Se forman en los días soleados.
Si cierran los ojos y piensan en una nube,
probablemente sea una de estas la que viene a la mente.
Todas las formas de nubes del comienzo
eran cúmulos.
Sus contornos nítidos y definidos
las hace las mejores para encontrar formas en ellas.
Y nos recuerda
lo intrascendente que es observar nubes,
la actividad tan anodina que es.
No van a cambiar el mundo
tendiéndose boca arriba y mirando hacia el cielo.
Es inútil. Es una actividad inútil,
y por eso, precisamente, que es tan importante.
El mundo digital conspira para hacernos sentir
eternamente ocupados, permanentemente ocupados.
Ya saben, cuando no están lidiando con
las presiones cotidianas de ganarse la vida
y llevar comida a la mesa, formar una familia,
escribir cartas de agradecimiento,
tienen que lidiar ahora con
una montaña de correos electrónicos para responder,
poner al día una página de Facebook,
actualizar su Twitter.
Y el observar las nubes legitima el no hacer nada.
(Risas)
Y a veces necesitamos...
(Aplausos)
A veces necesitamos excusas para no hacer nada.
Estas diosas patronas de los ociosos
nos tienen que recordar
que es bueno bajar el ritmo
y vivir el presente, no pensando
en lo que hay que hacer y lo que ya debería estar hecho,
sino tan solo en estar aquí, dejando que la imaginación
se aleje de las preocupaciones cotidianas de aquí abajo
y solo vivir el presente, porque es bueno para uno
y es bueno para el modo en que uno se siente.
Es bueno para las ideas. Es bueno para la creatividad.
Es bueno para el alma.
Así que sigan alzando su mirada,
admirando la belleza efímera,
y recuerden siempre vivir con la cabeza en las nubes.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)